[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jason's
with us in Hartford Connecticut hey
Jason welcome to the Ramsey Show thanks
Dave how you doing today better than I
deserve what's up man okay um yeah I'm a
long time uh listener and I'm a Long
Time Saver I was hoping you could answer
a question regarding a retirement uh
disagreement between my wife and I um
I'm 54 she's 51 um I'd like to retire
next year at 55 I feel like I have
enough uh savings to retire comfortably
maybe possibly do a side gig and um she
doesn't feel like we do so just asking
for some advice well retirement's not a
feeling so that's at least uh some
consolation to you we can look at some
facts and data to go all right do you
have the the finances to retire is your
nest egg big enough how much is your
nest egg dude um about two and a half
around two and a half million so she
needs more than a couple hundred
thousand a year to live on uh apparently
so what's your current
expenses um you know right now we're
probably about $8,000 a month okay so
you need $100,000 a year to live and 2
and A5 million invested in good mutual
funds if it made 10% would be$ 250,000
right correct now you don't you probably
don't have access to all of that at 54
do you no she's she's going to be
younger so she will probably work in
time and you can't access all the 2 and
a half million now at 54 years old some
of it's in 401s right correct some of it
is 59 and a half before you get to it
right have you got some money to live on
until you get to 59 and a half well she
can she she's actually employed she's uh
makes most of the money in the household
so what does she make she she makes
around 160 a year okay and your expenses
are 8,000 so if you weren't even there
she'd be okay
correct I think she's trying to tell you
something no she I I mean actually I I I
just just want to get out the corporate
okay so I I yeah there's a couple things
mathematically the answer is you're just
fine and I just outlined why yep as soon
as you get access to two and a half
million if it's invested well if you
pull off eight or 10% of that a year
regardless of whether she's working you
easily you're going to make more than it
takes to cover your expenses right
correct it's a math thing like George
said it's not a feeling but I think
there's a lot more going on here than
this well we're completely debt free we
no credit card no I mean she doesn't
want you sitting on at home on your butt
at 54 years old is no no it's not the
it's just going to be a career change
for me I'm I'm very handy side hustle is
different you know I want to do I want
to retire and do a side hustle I it's
not a side hustle it's a business retire
and open a business okay well we'll call
it a business yeah let start a small
business idea that makes more than you
used to make in corporate yep and then
then none of this is an issue so I I
just can't recommend I'm 63 and I can't
recommend you do nothing it's not worked
out from for most of my friends they die
no I'm not going to do anything trust me
we have a younger son that I actually
want to spend the Summers with so the
home the the business would give me the
flexibility to schedule work based on
his school schedule so if he was home in
the Summers I could spend more time with
him so this is kind of a work life
balance thing for
me yeah um you have the money to do
whatever you want I'm I'm now moving
from Financial to life do something okay
babysitting your kid in the summer going
from the with the net worth you have is
your only goal and calling that life
balance and making it sound cool is it's
going to wear pretty thin quick dude
you're going to want to go do something
with your life and you're too young to
do nothing you you're too valuable in
the marketplace so go do something with
your life that's just guy to guy right
there that has nothing to do with the
math the math is you're just fine and
I'm a think I kind of think in this
argument with your wife she's a little
bit worried about
that um I don't think so because I'm
pretty um I'm pretty involved in all
kinds of activities in Civics and that's
not the same thing well I have a lot of
activities to keep me busy that's for
sure that's not the same
thing I'm talking about being being of
marketplace value not simply serving the
JC's okay um and and so you can do
whatever you want to do I'm not I'm not
belittling you for that I'm just trying
to listen to what's going on here
because there's nothing in this math
that says you can't quit cold today all
the math says you can quit well the
issue for her is she just doesn't think
we have enough that's the thing she's
just worried that we're going to run out
of M have you shown her the expenses and
the net income and what the retirement
accounts will do yeah we've already met
with a planner and he says we're good to
go as well so well then she just doesn't
believe the data at that point lady that
makes $160,000 a year is not stupid so
what is she really saying that's what
I'm trying to figure out no she's just
she's she's always she's come from a
family where everybody works no that she
didn't come from a family where math
doesn't work math works All Families she
doesn't believe the math I'm telling you
well that that then that's a different
issue but she's not too stupid to
believe the math she's not wanting to
believe it for some reason and that's
your core issue it's not do I have
enough to retire it's how how do I deal
with my situation so I I have a friend I
talked to the other day he was one of
the he's like the sixth guy to ever go
through financial PE University wow he
called me up and I met with this
grandson that's how long ago this was
right met with his grandson the other
day who's a a millionaire because this
guy went through Financial Peace
University pretty cool so um but the
first time him and his wife walked in
she was a real estate agent and they had
$4 million they were in their 50s and
she thought she she worked like 80 hours
a week so on real estate she could not
relax and I sat down with the math and I
showed her the exact same math that he
had been showing her that $400,000 a
year 30 years ago $400,000 a year 30
years ago you know you you've got enough
you don't have to be in freakout mode
she relaxed calm down ended up selling
more real estate because she was in
freakout mode all the time and but it
was there was something it was an
emotional thing like with Jason's wife
because Jason's wife the lady I'm
talking about is not dumb she's
brilliant and Jason's wife not dumb they
don't generally pay dumb people 160
grand for much of anything generally not
for long anyway it catches up with you
being dumb but the uh but but the is it
the security gland that flared up could
be it could scarcity mindset potentially
like I knew a guy that was a billionaire
and I asked him why he worked all the
time and he said I grew up dirt poor and
I'm like well I I get that and he goes
no like the dirt the floor in our house
was dirt wow that's dirt poor in
Appalachia and he goes I can't get that
out of my system so I work all the time
like that's that's not a math problem
that's not a financial problem that's a
psychological problem you have a wound
from your past a trauma that you've not
overcome and and that's a Dr John
deloney answer it's not a George camel
Dave Ramsey answer right yeah well a lot
of that has to be dealt with if you're
going to ever think it's enough cuz
point you you get 20 million you go this
guy this guy had a billion it could all
go away at any time so I got to keep
stacking keep stacking yeah and and
listen you you can't get enough
godliness with contentment is great gain
Financial Peace create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life